[Musik]
ich bin gerade auf der ifa in berlin und
hierbei wunsch zeige ich euch den neuen
funktechnischen highlight einfach alles
passen sympathie ist die technik ist
als leistungs verhältnis stimmt heute
hier
richtig
[Musik]
also wir sind hier gerade backstage im
wohnwagen und hier kann ich mich
vorbereiten umziehen
vorne ist die vorbereitungs küche da
habe ich schon alles hergerichtet und
hat noch fleißige helfer in der küche
die mir die 500 600 teller dann auch
beim belegen und servieren helfen und
verbreiten die haare zurückbinden
[Musik]
natürlich nehme ich mein herz sprechen
können weil es so groß war
aber wir kollegen hier tauschen so
unternimmt aus ich mal vorbei gekommen
mainhausen
hast du was für mich böse frau echt war
ich weiß schon dass ich echt ganz
sensibel betrachtet
man kann nicht mehr ausleihen war
gestorben der würde glaube ich ganz gut
[Musik]
also ich hab nämlich einfach ein paar
wochen angerufen zb profis dann gibt es
mein hausaufgabenheft ist die
hausaufgaben hilft er sich selber
entdeckt haben
für uns da geht der komplette wir werden
ich habe meine stiftung
du bist ein flyer
raps
es ist nicht so schlimm als weltneuheit
berlin ots die konzertkarten von ghazi
minister ließ kann so viel wie noch mit
deinen und nochmals vom geht's mit rein
mit richtig cool und das sind liam
[Musik]
okay das ist kein döner messer sondern
ein brot und kuchen messer und wenn ein
messer brot und kuchen schneiden kann
kartoffelscheiben
[Musik]
hier wird gearbeitet wie am fließband
in diesen kursen an sorgen
flaschenverschlüsse von gvo diesen
aufrecht
[Musik]
das ist jetzt mein aufwand programm also
ich glaube jeder andere macht vor der
show so entstanden yoga massage und ich
bin so hardcore hier am
frank rost
[Musik]
auf
tom
ja
zwischen
ich kann nichts zum essen
trotzdem
[Musik]
[Applaus]
euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so hoffe ich angefangen
ich muss halt nie gemacht deswegen warum
also ausmaße annimmt
mit dem studium und mit der ausbildung
fertig und habe mich beworben an meiner
schule
[Musik]
ich hoffe
schneider
lima alle foul
[Applaus]
man weiß nicht mal was ich mache
sie denkt er ruft ihr arbeiten
zu hause auf
jetzt mal einfach ausgesetzt
dann wieder auf kuchen
und dann kleingebäck oder glänzen zum
beispiel die plätzchen würde ich jetzt
nehmen und dann ist wieder alles
eingestellt ich mach start und fertig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn es eine erste rate und da hab ich
mir jeden morgen mit der drei stimmen
gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
eigentlich ist
pol
[Musik]
ich bin sofort für dich da habe die 14
hier
und gemeinsam achtung
mit verve
ein ganz großes
die form ist ich schreibe vater kann man
da nicht schneien
ich mache ein riesengroßes hoher
zuwachsraten
ich brauch richtig viel dass klubs um
die letzte
der pinkfarbene tasche haben
hier wird
die
das ist ihr job
das ist mit das thema kohle neuen online
shop und der gesamte erlös geht an eine
stiftung ein schönes stück des stifters
grüne die dieses jahr helfen dürftigen
kindern die zwischen dem 1
fährt weg gefragt denn gc
zwischendurch kommt hier auch keinen
duft ein bisschen süß gerade noch 1 26
anhänger machen
ist ein notizblock damit das ausscheiden
unglaublich dankeschön waren wir noch
behauptungen zu sagen
nimmt noch hier backofen vielleicht
gewinnt einer das ist super
warten im den autor
bitte die kaufen ist gemeinsam mit der
wurst
dankeschön
tut mir leid ich habe zu viel zeit
verbraucht autogrammstunde ist vorbei
[Musik]
schwarz etwas neues
si
[Musik]
normalerweise kennt man ja die
haushaltsgeräte unter weißer ware bei
bosch wurde die weiße ware vor sprossen
waren hier sind wir technischen geräte
nicht nur technisch richtig putzt
sondern auf designmäßig also alle geräte
wurden in carbon black design gemacht
und die sind wirklich sagen habt also
wirklich ganz ganz tolles küchen wie
seid ihr seht hier die backöfen die
haben alle einen schwarzen griff in
schwarzen ring die kühlschränke sind
auch komplett in mattschwarz also
wirklich sensationell
ich würd ja normalerweise sagen eine
richtige männer küche aber selbst ich
als brauchen zusagen auch schön
deswegen habe ich auch schon bei uns zu
hause als neues technisches highlight
gibt es zb die wako mir schublade die es
hier direkt unter dem backofen da hat
man dann einfach oben drüber
an den kleineren backofen finde ich auch
richtig praktisch diva komische gerade
bietet wirklich verschiedene vorteile
man kann hier lebensmittel länger
haltbarer machen indem man sie dann
einfach in den beutel rhein gibt den
beutel hier einlegt und dann wird die
luft aus dem beutel rausgezogen
das kann man zum einen benutzten zum
beispiel als vorbereitung zum suite
jahren also wenn man fleisch nitrit
jahren möchte um auf den perfekten
garten zu kommen
oder man kann die lebensmittel länger
haltbar machen weil einfach der
sauerstoff entzogen wird chipstüten zum
beispiel wieder verschließen andere
lebensmittel haltbar machen wurst käse
in den kühlschrank geben und dadurch hat
man wirklich erinnerung viele vorteile
hier oben habt ihr dann auch direkt bei
der dampf funktion die suite funktion
und können so dann beide geräte optimal
verbinden
[Musik]
der kühlschrank der die farbe ändert das
ist der wahre boss
den habe ich letztes jahr schon gezeigt
hier natürlich in meiner lieblings front
farbe
hier gibt es aber fünf neue richtig
tolle farben und hier an der seite wird
oder umfrage gemacht für zwei weiter
[Musik]
hier gibt's dann eine neue keramik kommt
die wird aus 1 2 und 3 ausgesucht und
eine muster front und dies einfach aus
einer kooperation mit weiß entstanden
die kunden dürften hier einfach
vorbeikommen an der kundenumfrage
teilnehmen und die freue mich mit den
meisten likes wird dann gewinnen und
dann gibt es die auch bald auf der ifa
hat mir oft als konsument das problem
man war letztes jahr schon auf der ifa
hat eine richtig coole sensation gesehen
hat sie sich gleich gekauft weil man
begeistert ist im nächsten jahr kommen
wieder und sieht was besseres und denkt
sich na toll
letztes jahr habe ich gekauft jetzt
brauche ich wieder was neues herr
porsches ist wirklich nicht so bei
branche smokings motto smarter day
smartphone euro wer letztes jahr zum
beispiel diesen kühlschrank gekauft hat
dass es nämlich einen kühlschrank mit
integrierter kamera
das heißt ich kann mich mit der home
connect app connecten
und sie dann was es in meinem
kühlschrank drin kann von überall aus
zugreifen und bisher war einfach der
vorteil man konnte überall auf seinem
handy sehen was habe ich in meinem
kühlschrank was fehlt mir noch oft gehe
ich zum beispiel zum einkaufen und
vergessliche zu zehnt da habe ich keine
mehr aber eben doch noch dazu obwohl es
doch zu hause ab jetzt hat man aber noch
mehr vorteile uns war erkennt die kamera
was im kühlschrank erst gibt dir die
perfekte lage möglichkeit also zum
beispiel milchprodukte hier lagern
fleisch weiter unten andere dinge weiter
oben so sind die lebensmittel länger
haltbar und ihr könnt euch direkt unter
home connect damit verbinden und bekommt
sofort rezeptvorschläge weil die kamera
zb die zucchini erkennt die eier dazu
seht und gleich kombiniert was kannst du
aus diesen zutaten zaubern und das geht
eben nicht nur mit diesen kühlschrank
sondern auch mit dem hübschen kenia zum
beispiel letztes jahr gekauft haben also
richtig drauf
[Musik]
für mich das smartphone hier echt die
tollste innovation auf der ifa
denn wer kennt es nicht zu hause ihr
möchtet kräutertee heimann gelangten in
der küche habe basilikum zum beispiel
geht ja noch kürzester zeit kaputt weil
einfach die licht und wasserverhältnisse
nicht mehr stimmen was das schlimmste
ist man hat immer obst bewegungspausen
die sich einfach in der erde aufsetzen
denn wer zu viel gibt da schimmelt die
erde und dann hat man direkt zu hause
hier hat man wirklich ein tolles
nachhaltiges konzept und zwar kommt das
ganze ohne erde aus ich hab hier die
kapsel und als lavastein rolle drin
da kann man dann die samen einsetzen
kann man auswählen zwischen 40
verschiedenen oder auch ganz eigene
auswählen und hier ist das smartphone
man kann sich das so vorstellen wie bei
menschen ein baby zum beispiel doch ganz
andere nährstoffe ein ganz anderes essen
als ein erwachsener und so ist es auch
hier
ich nehme das hier mal weg
und sobald die pflanze etwa dieser höhe
erreicht hat kommt das zwischenstück
drauf und das ganze funktioniert so
unten das wasser drin
dann wird das wasser nach oben gepumpt
die samen werden befeuchtet und das
restliche wasser fließt dann wieder ab
einfach damit keine staunässe entsteht
und eben auch nicht riechen kann und
nichts kümmern kann
dann kommt hier das licht drauf und das
ist eigentlich ein blaues licht aber
unser auge erkenntnis als pink was ich
natürlich sehr schön finde und das licht
braucht die pflanze um einfach zu
wachsen und so könnt ihr dann die
pflanze drei monate lang ernten also
immer wieder abschneiden die maxon darin
wächst auch wieder nach und nach drei
monaten könnt ihr einfach die kapsel
austauschen neue samen ein sache beim
smartphone die vorteile dass man bis zu
400 prozent mehr vitamine hat über 40
verschiedene kräuter anbauen kann und
das 365 tage im jahr
und wenn ich mir dann zu hause auch hin
hänge sowie im hintergrund kann sich
sogar der morath darunter stellen und
vielleicht wächst da ja auch ein
bisschen schneller mit
[Musik]
massive schäden gibt es ja einige und
man kennt auch schon länger dass sie das
waschmittel auch richtig dosieren hier
wenig es aber noch richtig genial die
waschmaschine hat eine eingebaute waage
denn ich kenne von zu hause bei uns
rechts hatte moratti wäsche aber ich
bereits thema vor und trennen wir alles
ganz schön und wir können nie so richtig
abschätzen wie viel die wäsche weg man
kennt sie auch vom kofferpacken
damit lädt man entweder zu viele oder
sein doch zu wenig und hier kann man
einfach die tür öffnen und zum beispiel
so wie hier die handtücher nehmen
einzig ein
nun entsteht direkt wie viel man eben
noch einladen kann und das finde ich
echt cool weil gerade bei handtüchern zu
schätzen dass ich mal gerne oder
bettwäsche kleidung so kann die
waschmaschine sondern direkt auf das
gewicht der wäsche abgestimmt auf die
wasserhärte eingestellt hier den
reiniger einfach dosieren und hier finde
ich ganz gut
ich benutze zum beispiel zu hause keinen
weichspüler weil einfach die menschen
kaputt macht das heißt ich habe nur zwei
waschmittel einmal für weiße wäsche und
einmal für bunte wäsche in bunter wäsche
darf er kann gleich mittendrin sein
hier können sich also zwei verschiedene
einführen einmal ein gefüllt haben
gleich die verpackung entsorgen und die
waschmaschine erledigt dann alles ganz
alleine
und sie haben wir den red dot design
award winner 2018
diese waschmaschine wurde nämlich
ausgezeichnet wegen ihrem schönen design
aber für mich hat sie noch viel viel
mehr als nur tolles design denn das ist
eine waschmaschine und einen trockner in
einem und die waschmaschine wert bis zu
zehn kilo wäsche und trocknet ist zur
sechs kilo wäsche und der
durchschnittliche haushalt menschen etwa
drei bis vier kilo
aber ich hier bekommt man eben auch
große bettdecken mit reinen können sie
anschließend direkt trocknen und das
finde ich echt super praktisch bei
waschmaschinen haben natürlich also das
waschmittel wird perfekt dosiert hier
habe ich die funktion dass ich die
wäsche direkt mit abwägen kann und hier
habe ich die doppelfunktion dass sich
eine waschmaschine mit integriertem
topfen habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
smartbooks hängt natürlich bei smarten
rezepten an und ihr wahrscheinlich alles
schon meine rezepte bereich simple
jammeh entdeckt da gibt es hier
natürlich schon aber ich glaube wir
können jetzt mal die katze aus dem sack
lassen
ihr fragt ja alle immer schon nach einer
stelle und eines cds fühlte ich mir auch
schon ziemlich lange wir sind auch schon
sehr lange dran aber das ganze bedeutet
natürlich auch prompt ein bisschen mehr
erfahren so was kann man nicht von heute
auf morgen aufbauen
und deswegen haben wir uns zufällig mit
unserem partner bosch eine gemeinsame
ist alijew zu machen das richtig coole
daran ist da gibt's nicht nur die
rezepte sondern ihr könnt wie in der
home connect einfach die rezepte dort
anschaut und dann damit die rezepte zb
die backofen einstellung temperatur und
so weiter alles direkt an den backofen
schicken oder andere haushaltsgeräte und
somit der cfd posch geräte steuern also
wer jetzt von den backofen von bosch hat
der kann später meine sally apps
herunterladen
ihr habt dann schon euren backofen und
können dann immer wieder einfach neue
updates draufladen also heute schon die
technik vor
[Musik]
das auto gefahren ist schon seit vielen
jahren im gespräch und irgendwann in den
nächsten jahren wird definitiv kommen
natürlich ist hier auf branche ganz
vorne mit dabei bosch meldet jeden tag
16 neue patente arm und gehört weltweit
zu den innovativsten unternehmen und
hier geht es nicht ums auto haben sich
also um die hardware sondern um die
software und ich muss sagen ich hatte
immer bauchschmerzen damit wenn ich sage
euch verträumt komplett auf die technik
das auto fährt alleine aber man hat ja
heutzutage schon diese technischen
innovationen zum beispiel von bosch im
auto ich kenne schon den
bremsassistenten den spurassistenten
haben wir auch im auto und ich muss auch
sagen ich vertraue darauf das auto
reagiert viel schneller als ich es
jemals beim bremsen machen könnte was
ich ja auch ziemlich cool findet man
setzt sich dann ins auto rein vor der
kamera sein gesicht wird gescannt um das
auto wird direkt auf seine bedürfnisse
eingestellt also alles personalisierten
hier zum beispiel mit anschlägen da ist
im luftstrom und wenn ich die hans
anhebe rufe ich das menü auf
hier ist dann die kamera für meine augen
und ich kann mit dem auge auch wirklich
frontal auf der straße bleiben und es
erkennt dann was ich hier auswähle also
schon ein bisschen raffiniert jetzt
schaue ich hier zum beispiel auf die
home kollektion jetzt in die mitte da
ist das symbol für meine playlist das
navi das funktioniert recht einfach mal
hier die kamera ist und dann kann dies
einfach auswählen
klappt recht gut also schlecht punkt das
autonome fahren funktioniert auf der
autobahn das heißt im ort entfernt man
noch ganz manuell sobald man auf die
autobahn fährt fährt das lenkrad ein
also man kann es zusammenklappen und
dann kann man sich entspannen
ich habe mir im wahrsten sinne des
wortes eine coole innovation von porsche
übernimmt nicht nur verantwortung für
uns menschen hier in deutschland sondern
auch für die ganze welt
und wenn man mal an die ärmeren länder
denkt und an die dritte welt denkt zum
beispiel an die sub sahara wo die
temperaturen wirklich sehr rein kommt
die luft trocken ist
dann hat man hier einfach die
möglichkeit diese tools zur verwendung
die toolbox kommt komplett ohne strom
aus das heißt es richtig nach 30 und
funktioniert mit wasser
hier fühlt man einfach seine
lebensmittel rein hier das wasser
verschließt die box und das
physikalische r gleich gar nicht aber
das besondere ist einfach je heißer und
trockener ist draußen ist umso besser
wird gekühlt martin einfach nur die
möglichkeit die lebensmittel um 10 grad
weniger als die außentemperatur zu
kühlen es hat einfach für den menschen
dort den vorteil dass die lebensmittel
nicht so schnell verderben sie halten
zehn tage länger drinnen und das ist
wirklich toll
sie müssen nicht mehr jeden tag zum
lebensmittel holen gehen und
kilometerweit laufen sondern schon
einmal die woche da hingehen ihre
zutaten hier lagern sie bleiben schön
frisch verderben nicht und das ist
wirklich was richtig tolles also da muss
ich sagen das ist wirklich auch eine
herzensangelegenheit und ich finde ganz
tolle frau schlussendlich gingen sie
haben wir noch ein tolles gadget für die
küche und zwar ein projektor
so hat man
sie ein integriertes touchscreen direkt
auf der küchen arbeitsfläche
das ganze wird dann am küchenschrank zb
installiert und macht keine probleme und
vor allen dingen können auch die finger
mal verschmiert sein
auf der küchen arbeitsfläche macht ist
hier ist eine kamera
das heißt die steuert dann meine finger
und erkennst du und ich kann hier
beispielsweise in der youtube die silly
rezepte haben schauen oder später in der
zelle einfach die rezepte aufrufen
direkt alles wieder mit dem backofen mit
dem herd kombinieren und verbinden
aber hier auch ganz viele tolle andere
gadgets wie zb das zeige ich euch hier
ihr kennt das doch wenn ihr eine torte
gebacken habt oder einem buch
und dann wisst ihr nicht so genau wie
schneide ich die torte jetzt eigentlich
in gleichmäßige stücke dann gehe ich
hier auf dieser zusatzfunktion sliding
kennt dann auswählen auch quadratisch
rechteckig oder zum beispiel rund wir
gehen jetzt mal aufgrund die stelle
jetzt mal meine torte drauf das war
jetzt so das typische moratti stück also
murat die hälfte und ich die hälfte
und hier könnt ihr dann einfach anhand
der portionen auswählen wenn jetzt noch
mehr gäste mal da sind hier einfach mit
dem finger entlang fahren
jetzt sind wir zum beispiel 19 personen
eine davon des monats der kriegt das
größte stück und die anderen raum
gleichmäßig gesteckt
ich konnte euch jetzt hier bei bosch gar
nicht alles zeigen es gibt noch viel
viel tolle neuheiten und innovationen
aber ich habe glaube ich so die
highlights gezeigt angefangen bei der
box die wirklich nur mit wasser
funktioniert und komplett ohne strom
auskommt was sehr nachhaltig ist weiter
geht's mit dem autonomen fahren mit den
assistenten für mehr sicherheit auf der
straße eidos die waschmaschine das sieht
und somit nachhaltig mit die umwelt und
natürlich auch für den geldbeutel ist
und für die design liebenden sek und lag
serie auf jeden fall richtig tolles
highlight
[Musik]
das war ein guter freund er dass er
ich bin glücklich teil des geldes mit
smart
zusammen ist man einfach kein kraut
ausgeschüttet
oder kommen
[Musik]
an der gv besuchen sie auch immer gerne
an freunde und bekannte jetzt zb bei
kindern gut geht dass die
richtig toll haben und ich habe gerade
mit dem canon mit ihm gesprochen und
nicht nur schöne an euch bald
wenn ihr also eine küchenmaschine
gewissen möchte dann kommentiert mit
candle schefflenz
und dann einfach den der bitte ihr gerne
haben möchte
selbst hier noch place green das bist du
wer schon eine kennwort flüchten
maschine hatten 79 bestimmt auch für
neue zubehörteile
ich habe ich jetzt gleich zwei neue
ämter
es war einmal der cenote schuss ab den
wenn ich aber mit nach hause nehmen und
zeigt euch dann richtig genau in einem
video fast alles zaubern kann dann kann
man nämlich richtig schonend gemüse obst
vorzubereiten
und hier gibt's noch ein zubehörteil was
ich genial finde und war das motto ist
er in meinem besser einfach einen
smoothie zu bereiten
also hier wohnte mitte sagt
rucola
darf man gleich de moura probieren
habe ich noch erdbeeren pflaumen alles
mit rein
noch ein bisschen wasser
max deckel drauf
und dann direkt auf den wecker
und anschalten
[Musik]
schrauben wird müsste dance mutig gar
nicht erfüllen sondern einfach den mix
deckel weg
[Applaus]
den fahrplan zur besser
dann gleich was für unterwegs zu groß
[Musik]
gibt es schon lange die röhre und die
hilfefunktion lag eine küchenmaschine
hat vielleicht etwas tolles innovativ
ist
nach italien und es ruft einfach die
ganze zeit die sachen im kopf weil man
das so machen möchte oder auch andere
dinge die ständig geführt werden müssen
geben das ganze kostet später ist
einfach 50 euro
ich finde es ist echt ein preis das zu
fahren
lasst uns mal was bringt
[Musik]
dass wir das schon sagen ich bin eine
gute ehefrau und mutter hausfrau
und ich liebe meinen haushalt ich liebe
es die küche zu erkunden
aber wenn es etwas gibt was ich hatte
und ich meine wirklich hoffe dann wird
einfach übel
ich mag es einfach nicht so umständlich
und immer diese riesen dampf optionen
ich weiß es einfach zu umständlich und
dampf station an sich finde ich genial
weil es einfach schon mal besser bügelt
als die normale bügeleisen
ich glaube jeder kennt hier dieses
normale bügeleisen und hat
wahrscheinlich auch jeder zu hause oder
hatte zu hause und das problem ist
einfach immer beim bügeln
man geht er nach vorne und die hälfte
der zeit kommt er auch wieder zurück
hierbei den taschen bleiben gleich schon
mal wieder hängen dann kommst du hier
nicht über die knöpfe hast du schon mal
ziemlich nervig und darmstadt irland ich
finde ich zwar gut aber sie haben
umständen ich weiß einfach viel zu groß
sind viel zu schwer und ich habe keinen
raps die jeden wie
zu verstauen uns hierbei brauchen wir
einfach eine bin ich das irgendwie
ziemlich kleiner so dass sie meine
handfläche und das ganze ist hier
abgerundet wie so ein snowboard also
kann ich damit
und ich glaube vielleicht macht mir das
ein bisschen mehr spaß kann ich damit
wirklich nach vorne zurück gerätes ohne
hängen zu bleiben
es gibt hier in der tasche nicht mehr
hängen
ich kann auch sogar über die klappe
bügeln
für alle mittels klein genug um seine
chance zu verstehen
wenn ich neben meiner seele
[Musik]
eigentlich seine kochshow fressen
schweinrich
das sind auf der suche nach den neuen
und was ich sehen wollte
foto
lausanne
umgeleitet
sämtliche flüge leisen habe ich mich
verbrannt aber das andere ist groß
ab dem 1
[Musik]
wobei samsung der zweitgrößte
handyhersteller weltweit und die arbeit
noch mit der telekom zusammen und bauen
das ganze drei und vier gehen alle denkt
über das apple auf platz eins ist aber
ist ja gar nicht die sind nämlich erst
auf platz drei und die kamera qualität
die wir zu recht immer besser und hier
richtig viel spaß
[Musik]
cooles video
eigentlich verbietet die technik ja und
wird sie vom hintergrund überall dieser
verbrechen jeder für sich alleine und
spielen als virtuell irgendwie mit
anderen also voller technik davon die
echte welt nicht vergessen
[Musik]
ich habe eine ganz tolle innovation und
zwar ein sensor für die windel
sie muss sagen dass ich es für die
babywindel ein bisschen die wirklich
findet er nicht als mama oder als papa
merkt natürlich auch die windel von bp
voll ist der sensor misst die
feuchtigkeit und auch die temperatur und
schickte das dann aufs handy
und dann sagt auch hier jetzt höchste
zeit wenn du zu wechseln
wie gesagt bei babys finde ich ein
bisschen was mache ich als mama selber
aber ich bin schon richtig tolle und
innovative lösungen zum beispiel wird
die altenpflege in altersheime und muss
sowieso personalmangel ist kann man
sowas wirklich ganz toll einsetzen und
man kann dann auch sagen okay ab 80
prozent feuchtigkeit zum beispiel und
diese und jene temperatur dann gehe ich
hier nun wird benachrichtigt und dann
kann man eben die windel wechseln also
wirklich tolle innovation alex was sagst
du zu neuen carbon black reihe
black is beautiful
semenya
gesehen haben sollten
so ich sag's dir gleich aber was ich da
der oberhammer magst du nicht mehr um
seine frau sechs jahre und möglicher
klein genug und kann auch bei uns vor
sechs jahren hier kennengelernt auch das
motto auf der ifa
ist kein fake vorsicht und gehalt
doch ich hatte damals das cover
wir suchen jetzt ich bin schon ein
modisches vorbild
wir sind nicht geworden 26 jahre das ist
kein fake so cool zu bleiben
wir werden nicht mehr hätte gemeinsam
heute heute höher megane coupe du dir
die karre und black reihe an
ich geh und sucht er rief chef de haben
sie meine freundin und ich will selber
später fertig habe jetzt gesagt ich gehe
jetzt zum fifa-chef und löcher jeden mit
ein paar fragen der reform also die ifa
ist wirklich eine top organisierte
messen wir sind wirklich viel auf messen
unterwegs und man muss schon sagen
wirklich gut organisiert alles
strukturiert aber wahrscheinlich auch
ziemlich viel arbeit
ehrlicherweise natürlich ist es arbeit
aber es ist arbeit die macht sehr viel
spaß
wir sagen nicht umsonst immer wir
arbeiten in der geilsten branche die es
gibt und das nicht nur weil das
organisieren spaß macht dann wirklich
weil die produkte mit dem wir es zu tun
haben ja tagtäglich sind einfach die
innovativsten es sind die die tollsten
die sind hoch vernetzbar und
ehrlicherweise sie interessieren fast
jeden durch jeder altersgruppe liegt auf
jeden fall wie lange ist man schon dabei
bei der ifa in 2005 eingestiegen das ist
damals war die veranstaltung noch zwei
jährlich um sie dann in die herrlichkeit
überführt dann kann irgendwann die
sogenannte weiße ware die elektro
hausgeräte dazu das war mir jahr 2008
unser dem internationaler denn je größer
denn je effizienter und wertvolle ringe
und kann zurückblicken sagen welche
innovationen für dich bisher am kultur
ehrlicherweise was wir jetzt gerade
sehen nämlich den schritt über i
die spracherkennung in die voice
erkennung dass es für mich ein
riesenschritt nach vorne dass man so
schön sagt jp ist sogar die umstellung
von den röhrenfernseher in flache
tv-geräte war jetzt haben wir wirklich
mit innovation zu tun die nicht nur für
ältere erfahrbar sind essbar sind
sondern wo jeder wirklich entwickle ich
sagen kann
bitte mach jetzt was was ich will und
zwar aufgrund von einer stimme es ist
einfach fantastisch erzählungen und
verlief an neulinge also jemand hätte
liefern noch nie besucht hat weil ich
kann es jedem empfehlen also wirklich
für die ganze familie ist was dabei was
was redest ich mal einen tag reicht
sowieso nicht aus man muss man sie durch
mehrere tage einplanen
aber wo geht man am besten hilft also
wenn man wirklich vielen gefühlen möchte
wo das wo das herz der niederschläge
wirkliche innovationen gelebt werden wo
wirklich neuheiten nur so sprudeln ja
dann bitte unbedingt in die halle 26 in
unser ifa netz gehen dort finden wir 150
start ups die sich zusammen mit
industrie playern die sehr bekannt sind
auch im bereich der spracherkennung sich
ständig ein battle liefern und zwar
neueste lösungen erklären sie stehen auf
bühnen die leute dann ganz genau was das
tollste und sexy ist dann einer
bestimmten innovation ist und wer wird
da nicht angefasst wird wäre da nicht
das bett mit fast wird der ist kein
mensch aber ich glaube einmal dagewesen
du kommst immer wieder und kann zu sagen
welches highlight dieses jahr seinen top
favoritin
das ganz gemein schwierig muss
ehrlicherweise sagen es ist für mich
etwas ganz simpel ist ich bin sehr viel
unterwegs auf sehr vielen kontinenten
unterwegs weil wir in den globalen
headquarter immer um die budgets auch
für diese veranstaltung linien und
kämpfen und für mich ist etwas simples
wie ein kopfhörer mit noise cancelling
der extrem gut ausgesteuert ist und da
gibt es eine führung eine japanische
firma die hat das hier auch auf der
pressekonferenz vorgestellt und firma
sony und ich liebe ist ich muss sagen
ich bin okay wir schauen dann auf jeden
fall noch mal reiten halle 26 da gehen
wir jetzt mal werden und schauen was es
da alles zu lernen
[Musik]
auf schritt und tritt
15 jahre
mehr
vor allem vermutet das ist groß allein
ist eine tasche verletzt
[Musik]
ich habe irgendwie das gefühl ich weiß
auch nicht aber ich habe erfolg zu haben
wie komme ich da drauf einfach
einsteigen ein paar gott
[Gelächter]
ein moment
so geht es nicht
wenn morgens eigentlich kurz zu fassen
wenn man sich hier
bisher kamen nach toren
[Musik]
wenn sie mit dem abbieger ja gerne ein
bisschen in den knien und ich glaube ich
sehe aus wie sony die jungs hier drauf
ich weiß auch nicht er machte so
professionell
ja mach du mal das
war zu weit getrieben
die sowieso aussieht wie mache ich mach
das nochmal
ich bin so wie sie werden überrascht
sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wahnsinn
keine angst keine kleine kinder fast
auch okay ist richtig gehen ja alles tun
oder halt das spielzeug heimerdingen mit
den knien die kuh laufende ja ihr habt
gesehen
ich hab mir weitermachen gießen ersten
mal in meinem leben glauben dass ich
besser als bei den bauer spielen
[Musik]
gibt's im ersten fliegenden luftreiniger
also das ist eine drohne die fliegt
einfach ganz vor allem auch darum eine
genussvolle zum beispiel dass man nicht
aufpasst
von der idee eigentlich ziemlich cool
aber ihr habt schon nicht anzutreten er
so ziemlich aus blut ist zwar sauber ist
das bekommen hat und ich mein wenn der
monat im raum essen
doch sie lässt an
passt der
in bewegung
[Musik]
einfach so der wein ist reif
normalerweise mag ich ja gerne süße
sachen aber zum wein passt doch was
schönes herzhaftes sally zaubert neue
kreationen für ein weinfest am herz
aufgebacken kann man viel mehr
improvisieren zwiebelkuchen gemüse tat
und kies traditionelles einfach mal
anders bin so gespannt ob es gut ankommt
einfach sally sonntag 16 uhr